(sexy moaning)
(keyboard typing)
- Hey
(sexy moaning)
We have a meeting in five minutes.
- What?
Yeah, yeah, okay.
(heavy breathing)
- Our client thought the final product was
- So good
- Brittany, you'll be teaming
up with Kelsey on this one.
- Why?
- You're both always on top of it.
(moaning)
- Okay.
- Hey, so we should probably
talk about that project.
Oh Jesus, ah God, I'm so-
I'm so wet.
- No.
- God damn it you got me-
So wet.
- Okay maybe we could just like
work this out over email, or,
kind of like, do it on
our own or something.
- Uh no, we need to-
Do it together.
Okay...
(sexy moaning)
(spanking)
- Oh God, gotta get out of here.
(sexy moaning)
Move motherfucker, move!
(typing)
Hey
- Oh, you came.
(echoes)
You, came, you came, you came.